it's an image at odds with the country's
healthy environmentally friendly
reputation but for years switzerland's
been a haven for tobacco firms with some
of the most lax laws in europe
sunday's referendums changed things with
voters defying the government and
approving a ban on tobacco advertising
and newspapers the internet anywhere
young people can see them
it's laughable that for two years now a
health policy to fight covert 19 has
been in place and now we really have the
opportunity to introduce a new health
policy yet the swiss government has
advised people to vote no for me it's
obvious that we have to vote yes to the
ban those backing the ban say the
government's opposition is down to the
presence of the world's major tobacco
companies several have their
headquarters here and the industry
generates more than six billion dollars
a year for the swiss economy but the old
economic arguments no longer hold sway
there are nine thousand smoking related
deaths a year in the country
the impact on its health system is now
at the forefront of people's minds
i voted in favor of banning tobacco
advertising on minors i think the only
argument of the opponents was the
collapse of the swiss economy i don't
see how it is linked maybe i didn't
understand well but it seems more
important to me to protect children from
tobacco
the tobacco firms have lobbied hard to
avoid the ban with opponents claiming
cake and even sausages could face
similar restrictions but the campaign
failed to convince most people swiss
voters showing politicians and big
business that it's time to get tougher
on tobacco
neve barker al jazeera